à mon avis ça va arriver ça y est ils
vont devoir porter l'uniforme et les et
voilà les les élèves c'est quand même un
truc de fou bon il y en a beaucoup qui
sont pour puisquil y a un sondage qui
est sorti 71 % des Français sont pour
l'uniforme on va avoir il moi c'est éc
nolo qui arrive
et revenante Fabrice divisio qui sera là
dans un instant bien entendu qui VI lui
il est pour il est pour l'uniforme
Fabrice il nous dira pourquoi dites-nous
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
êtes-vous pour le retour de l'uniforme
oui non chez vous aussi on a envie de
savoir ce que vous en pensez petit recap
et on y va c'est quoi toi je suis pas
sûr que ça soit une solution miracle qui
permette de régler tous les problèmes de
l'école mais en tout cas je pense
qu'elle mérite d'être testée et moi je
suis très favorable à l'expérimentation
pour qu'elle puisse faire avancer le
débat il y a un certain nombre d'élus ou
d'établissements qui ont manifester ces
dernières semaines leur souhait de
pouvoir expérimenter l'uniforme ou la
tenue scolaire unique je les invite à se
rapprocher de mes services je
présenterai à l'automne le cadre dans
lequel l'expérimentation pourra se
dérouler et ça y est pour voilà alors
Gabriel Atal voilà qui a lui-même en a
parlé un peu partout c'est vrai que
plusieurs personnalités se sont exprimé
sur le sujet et sont favorables même
s'ils sont pas tous d'accord concernant
les modalités de mise en place de cette
réforme regardez je suis pour la blouse
voir l'uniforme je trouve que l'uniforme
c'est absolument charmant dans les
écoles britanniques ou les écoles
asiatiques où je l'ai vu ça existe dans
territoire d'outremer ça existe dans nos
écoles privées dans la ville ça
remettrait dans nos écoles publiques et
bien
un minimum d'égalité je suis favorable à
une tenue scolaire dans les quartiers
très très populaires d'où je viens non
si on le fait il faut ouvrir cette
possibilité partout il y a pas de raison
d'ajouter à cette question une question
culturellement difficile une ségrégation
par le milieu socioculturel dans lequel
on vit alors merci éc nolo merci Yan MOX
d'être avec nous vous êtes la BRI la
brigade de répression de l'info Fabrice
divisio est avec nous également ce soir
pour vous éc nolo c'est oui ou c'est non
l'uniforme c'est oui alors j'étais déjà
favorable je suis encore plus favorable
depuis le débat d'hier ah oui avec cet
étrange personnage ce père d'élèves vouz
pour on va le faire revenir si vous
voulez oui je veux bien parce que j'ai
appris des choses sur internet
aujourd'hui alors il faut vérifier sur
Internet tout n'est pas parole
d'évangile ça oui oui il y a eu des
choses qui ont circuléah si vous voulez
on peut le faire revenir demain si vous
voulez non mais moi je je veux bien
redébattre sur ces bases là parce que
c'est pas tout à fait le personnage
qu'on nous a présenté mais bon et ben on
fera revenir demain et on va voir s'il
veut bien revenir en tout cas toujours
est-il que devant la mauvaise foi de
quelqu'un qui vous dit que laaba n'est
pas un vêtement religieux l'uniforme ou
en tout cas une tenue uniforme pas un
uniforme militaire une tenue uniforme ça
serait une bonne manière de régler
définitivement le problème j'observe que
c'est déjà en vigueur je crois en Guyane
en Guadeloupe et que ce sont pas des
régions qui ont versé dans le fascisme
ça c'est la la première chose la
deuxième chose ça permettrait de euh que
les les jeunes se déprennent un peu de
l'emprise des marques sur eux
c'està-dire en ayant une tenue plus
uniforme qui fasse moins je déteste
salaire oui non je sais que vous êtes
très très hostile au je déteste ça il y
en a qui sont moins résistants que vous
à l'appel des marques c'est
c'est sympa donc je je je trouve que ce
serait c'est une bonne double idée voilà
alors après il faut pas que ça soit le
remède miracle l'uniforme c'est une
bonne chose mais il faut que ça soit
accompagné par le rétablissement de
l'autorité euh des profs le
rétablissement la verticalité le
rétablissement des de l'enseignement des
savoirs fondamentaux c'est pas
l'uniforme ensuite tout va s'arranger y
max ce qui me dérange dans cette affaire
moi je suis contre c'est comme si si
vous voulez un spécialiste du cinéma
érotique connaîtrait toutes les
positions du kamasoutra mais ignorerai
le missionnaire en gros je exp alors
attendez parce que je remets tout ça en
place attendez de petites secondes que
je remets tout ça en place d'accordexque
pourquoi bon j'ai compris dites pas ça
devant Raymon s'il vous plaît juste à
côté merci c'est mettre la charue avant
les B c'est que l'école a tellement fait
peu montre d'autorité qu'elle est obligé
maintenant de déguiser des élèves comme
au bon temps de l' RTF et d'ailleurs
j'aurais pu venir aussi à l'émission en
panard et regardez trois chaînes en noir
et blanc et vous seriez-vous sur une des
trois chaînes de l' RF avec le talent
que vous avez on le sait et on
écouterait aussi des disques sur des
manches disquees ça serait très
intéressant de revenir en avril 1971
enfin plutôt 63 parce que c'est mes 68
qui a enlevé les uniformes ce qui ont
les études qui ont été faites aux
États-Unis très sérieuses sur le sujet
montrent que même si l'idée est
séduisante il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre le l'uniforme et le sentiment
d'appartenance il n'y a pas de
corrélation entre le sentiment
d'autorité et le port de l'uniforme et
surtout et c'est ça le plus important
c'est qu'en France les différenciations
sociales ne se font pas au niveau
microscopique mais au niveau
macroscopique c'est que au sein d'une
classe les gens défavorisés sont stockés
sont parqués que les gens défavorisés
c'est entre les collèges qu'il y a des
inégalités c'est pas au sein d'une même
classe donc mettre des déguisements à
toutes les personnes d'un même collège
n'a aucun sens il faudrait faire un
brassage de collège à collège car c'est
au niveau des régions et des collèges
qu' y a des différences et enfin Cyril
ça c'est plus personnel je crois que les
enfants ont toute leur vie pour devenir
des gens qui ressemblent à des gens
l'uniformisation est insupportable déjà
que les professeurs les pauvres parlent
à des élèves génériques des élèves qui
n'intéressent qui ne s'intéressent pas à
ce qu'on dit puisque à qui on parle
quand on fait un cours à tout le monde
c'est-à-dire à personne donc il y a déjà
tellement pas de personnalisation qui
est faite à l'échelle des individus dans
une école et ils ont toutes leur vie
pour réciter la même grammaire les mêmes
fables que tout le monde et je crois que
c'est le moment où jamais de être le
plus original possible c'est l'enfance
puisqueaprès il sera trop tard pas mal
ce qu'il a dit je trouve vanchement
alors non non fa
divisio Fabrice
divisio en fait c'est toujours le même
problème c'est quand on prend une mesure
pour pr ça va le micro de Fabrice non
excuse-moi farice c'est pour toi mais
estce que il est bien branché ou pas en
régie il y a toujours quelqu'un on
t'entend Fabrice vas-y mon cher en fait
ça dépense qu'on en attend toujours le
même débat l'idée d'un uniforme pour
lutter contre le communautarisme
religieux ça me paraît une très mauvaise
idée en fait on lutte pas contre un
communautarisme potentiel par un autre
communautarisme c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe et l'idée de se dire que les
élèves vont vont arriver à l'école sans
être ce qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire
religieux pour certains c'est pas une
bonne idée et ça marche pas on fait pas
une mesure contre quelque chose on leur
demande pas de cesser d'être religieux
on leur demande de cesser de
paraîtreig
laïité c'est un autre débat laité que je
dis pas religion c'est
moi je suis c'est un débat parce que moi
je suis radicalement contre l'idée de ne
pas manifester sa religion je pense que
la religion n'est pas un gros mot dans
ce pays qu'elle soit musulmane juif ou
ce que vous voulez et qu'au contraire la
religion est une chance elle est une
opportunité pour la République avant
d'être voilà ça c'est non mais je je
j'ai j'ai bien compris que vous d'
recommencer à expliquer la laïcité c'est
d ça dépend ça dépend qu' le débat AC
noo si le débat c'est uniforme laicité
si effectivement vous concevez
l'uniforme comme attendez si vous
concevez l'uniforme comme moyen de
préserver la laïcité bah il y en a
d'autres je dire pourquoi celui-là plus
qu'un autre je voilà c'est non
l'uniforme il sert pas l'uniforme il
sert pas à ça l'uniforme c'est d'abord
vous l'avez souligné c'est une notion
d'appartenance c'est une notion
effectivement d'appartenance
communautaire précisément à la
communauté je vous rappelle qu'en
métropole vous avez deux lycées de
prestige qui ont l'uniforme c'est le
pritané qui est lycée militaire et la
Légion d'honneur à Saint-Denis bon et
donc c'est pas intéressant moi j'ai des
enfants qu' fait une scolarité à l'
interternationale dans des lycées
internationaux où ils avaient un
uniforme et en fait on s'aperçoit de
quoi on s'aperçoit que au fond et ben ça
renforce le sentiment d'appartenance à
la communauté éducative à la communauté
scolaire ce qui alors je sais bien que
les études on ont dit que c'est pas le
cas le fait est que quand vous
interrogez les élèves c'est comme ça
qu'ils le ressentent c'est point just
justement on est allé voir des élèves
pour leur parler deuniforme vous regardz
ce qu'ils en pensent les élèves et c'est
plutôt partagé hein Daniel vous êtes
pour l'uniforme lui vous bien sûr
commencez par
vous ça t'empêche de montrer comment
tuer moi j'étais habitué à avoir une
blouse donc pour moi c'est une bonne
chose ça met déjà aux élèves des règles
j'aime pas trop l'idée parce qu'après
par exemple si je voudrais parler à un
copain à moi ben il faudrait que je le
cherche pendant une heure voilà mais là
où je peux être d'accord là où je suis
d'accord avec Dolo sur sur un point
c'est que la première religion de France
qui rentre au collège c'est consumérisme
c'estàdire qu'en fait aujourd'hui on a
une notion évidente qui est que les
influenceurs ont un terrain de jeu sur
commerciaux de marque on un terrain de
jeu absolument extraordinaire
quelleécole puisque c'est le lieu où
passe passe plus minutes de vous parler
je comprends toujours pas si vous êtes
pour ou contre qu'est-ce quel est
peutêre parce que peut-être parce que
cher ami la réalité elle est pas aussi
peut-être parce que la réalité est pas
aussi maniquenne et que pour ou contre
c'estê pas aussi simple et que la nuance
parfois apporte du bien que bas en fait
c'est ça cy cet enfant vient de dire
quelque chose d'assez puissant il vient
de dire j'ai peur de ne pas retrouver
mon meilleur ami c'est dire qu'il pose
le problème de l'indiscernable et les
enfants aiment bien être discernés ils
n'aiment pas être confondu dans la ça va
les obliger à se démarquer autrement que
par le vêtement ça va les obliger à se
démarquer intellectuellement ça va les
obliger à se démarquer parce qu'ils vont
être drôles intelligents percutant et
cetera plutôt que parce qu'il ils ont le
le t-shirt ou le polo à la mode sinon tu
fais une couleur de cheveux le vêtement
c'est la personne mais la question poser
de petites maison une petitte minute oui
moi ça me plaît à tous les niveaux ça me
plaît au niveau social ça me plaît au
niveau différence économique ça me plaît
au niveau de ça me plaît à tous les
niveaux parce que à ce moment-là euh
quand quand tu croises un autre élève et
ben tu tu vois pas la différence et il
est considéré comme un autre et cette
notion de confréie entre collèg ça me
plaît énormément parce que ça crée une
solidarité entre les élèves du fait qui
qui se reconnaissent entre eux après ce
qui me chagrine peut-être c'est le fait
qu'il va y avoir des différences entre
les lycées il va y avoir des lycées qui
vont avoir des beaux uniformes des
lycées qui vont avoir des moins beaux
uniformes est-ce qu'il va avoir l'argent
pour fournir tous les uniformes est-ce
qu'on va autoriser c'est la même chose à
la télé he est-ce qu'on va autoriser les
ouais est-ce qu'on va autoriser les
foyers à acheter leur uniformes
eux-mêmes où est-ce qu'il va être fourni
par le lycée il y a beaucoup de choses
comme ça qu' faut mettre en parce que ça
va continuer à faire des différences
sociales entre les Foy il y a une
expérience faite dans la ville de Provin
ils sont aperçus qu'au bout de quelques
mois les élèves en fait mettaient plus
les uniformes mais qu' a pas de demande
socialeord pas demande sociale au nom de
problèm que ça va régler je trouve que
les problèmes que ça peut susciter sont
dérisoires ça va régler des problèmes
fondamentaux je regrette ça va régler le
problème de la laïcité parce que notre
ami d'hier soir et les autres vous allez
voir que ça va être la Guera là pour
l'instant il se calme un peu ils se font
oubli et ils vont revenir avec des
vêtements de plus en plus ambigu en
disant mais vous voyez c'est pas une
abaya le proviseur va dire sien est une
il va y avoir des débats sans fin
l'uniforme mais pas l'uniforme militaire
une tenue uniforme va régler ce problème
je veux des noms là un petit peu voilà
voà je déénon je Raymon vous pensez
alors parce qu'il y avait le débat de la
baaya il faut que tout le monde soit en
uniforme pareil pour effacer le débat de
la BAA je pense que c'est une man c'est
un truc uniforme donc on va remettre
tout le monde en uniforme moi je pense
que c'est pas une bonne idée l'uniforme
on est plus on est plus en 1970 on veut
tout payer par le téléphone on veut tout
payer par Internet on veut être dans un
monde de technologie on veut être en
2023 et on veut habiller tout le monde
de la même manière donc si on met c'est
quoi l'uniforme ça va être un jean et un
t-shirt un jean et un pull et une fille
elle s'a comment suis mal exprimé c'est
pas leour et le retour au téléphone F
non mais je suis curieux comment elle va
s'habiller la fille elle pourra plus
s'habiller avec un débardeur elle pourra
plus s'habiller avec une robe à fleur
elle pourra plus s'habiller comme elle
veutd bah oui la pauvre bah oui la
pauvre parce que je je pense que
aujourd'hui parce que il y a un une
confusion sur un sur un vêtement on va
punir tout le monde se RA moi j'aime
bien j'aime bien mon école de quand
j'étais petit moi j'aime bien l'école de
quand j'étais petit on s'habille avec
les nouvelles basket parce qu'ell
courent plus vite que les autres on
s'habille avec un nouveau jein on met un
suite des basket qui courent plus V
et celui qui peut pas se les acheter
mais il y a toujours des gens qui
peuvent se les acheter aujourd'hui les
gens vont pas l'école pied ilur PAsie
qui va le payer mais qui va
payer qui va payeré
est magique l'État c'est qui
l'État c'est
l'étation
est voé les
Français
jouran on peut payer les uniformesousour
de la table on payer les
uniformes qui va payer lesocations
auour'hui bien évidentends je trouve que
tu es un magnifique écrivain et auteur
plutô plutôt que de faire de la
politique moi je j'ai très peur quand tu
parles vraiment si c'est y a que ça qui
te fait peur ça va attends c'est non ne
t'inquiète pas tout simplement vraiment
et bien évidemment que si on commence à
rentrer dans un univers martial en
disant que les enfants do avoir
l'uniforme alors qu'en France si vous
allez dans les banlieu je sais pas s'il
y en a ici qui qui vont dans des
établissements en banlieu je pense pas
beaucoup bah allez voir et alleer mettre
des des vêtements aux enfants vous allez
voir ça va durer 48 heures le reste ça
va pas finir néanmoins néanmoins né
l'imposer non non mais mais justement
l'imposition excusez-moi attends L5
calmez-vous
truc en train de dire enain de dire je
en train de me dire que la France va
devenir peut-être comme l'IRAC
effectivement et en plus de cela et en
plus de cela et en plus de cela écoute
bien j'espère qu'un jour en France que
une femme sera présidente parce que ça
me fait royalement chier que ce soit des
mecs qui soi justement absolument pas
compétent là aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
actuellement l'école c'est déplorable et
au lieu d'aider les professeurs au lieu
d'aider les établissements qui sont dans
un état dégueulasse ils vont vous
chercher des des des des justement à les
habiller et ce que dit Raymond il a
raison où vous allez chercher l'argent
quand il y a des familles qui ont du mal
à acheter les fournitures scolaires
Jacques car je du nom moi je suis contre
parce que je pense que malheureusement
c'est la fausse bonne idée c'est qu'au
départ je me dis bah ouais c'est bien
c'est la solution effectivement par
rapport au débat qu'on a eu hier mais
j'ai j'ai j'ai je quand je regarde un
petit peu ce qui se passe dans le monde
j'ai l'impression que c'est la fausse
bonne idée parce que partout où ça
marche c'est dans des des pays où la
discipline est déjà très
stricte Japon Corée du Sud Angleterre
des pays où de toute façon on respecte
beaucoup les choses et je pense que on a
un problème de fond qui est bien plus
profond ici en France c'est que
malheureusement je pense que les gens
vont tourner en dérision parce que on va
décider quoi on va décider un jean et un
t-shirt c'est ce qu'a dit le Président
hier ça va être détourné par ailleurs il
y a un autre problème c'est que ça
intervient au moment de l'adolescence
l'adolescence c'est le moment où tu as
envie t'affirmer tu as envie de te
différencier tu as envie d'avoir des
couleurs flashies tu as envieah je me
suis baladé aujourd'hui j'ai vu des
filles sortir des collèges et des lycées
avec d'Er
àécole des produits de marque je sais je
pense que ça ça marchera pas je pense
que c'est malheureusement la fausse
bonne idée et puis par ailleurs je suis
assez d'accord il y a quelque part un
relant un peu martial en réalité ça date
de Napoléon ça venaient des militaires à
ce moment-là bah si c'est c'est la
réalité département français s appliqué
ils ont versé dans le co privé non mais
c'est pas ce que je veux dire mais c'est
pas ce que je veux dire c'est tu masques
les choses tu les masques les
choses solution vous ne voulez que des
problèmes s'il vous plaît Gill je veux
non pour l'instant parce que oui on
content du oui je suis content de
retrouver Fabrice il dit toujours aussi
n'importe quoi mais avec calme vous
dites l'uniforme c'est un ami c'est un
ami oui mais bon les amis peuvent dire
n'importe
quoi vous dites l'uniforme créé
l'appartenance à une communauté c'est
totalement faux il est prouvé que il est
prouvé que vous raisonn c'est le
contraire l'uniforme c'est l'inégalité
totale les uniformes sont détournées
quand des enfants mettent des uniformes
d'abord ça coûte 137 € en moyenne un
uniforme 1 Provin avait abandonné
l'expérience personne pouvait payer
ensuite il y a la différenciation par le
tissu c'est à travers le tissu que les
gens vont acheter des uniformes plus ou
moins chers les mais oui cy c'est prouvé
en fait le tissu va être plus ou moins
luxueux donc les familles richesuse es
dans le textile toi maintenant
bien
ir des uniformes beaucoup plus beau les
chaussures la différence va se faire par
les chaussures les cartables les
fournitures donc l'uniforme crée
l'inégalité c'est une hésie totale votre
uniforme mais bien sûr division dit
beaucoup de conneries mais Verdes
toujours
pluse tous ceux excusez-moi je vais me
référer à une expérience que des
millions d'entre nous on fait jouer au
football porter le même maillot ça crée
pas un sentiment de solidarité
ça crée pas un sentiment de solidarité
dans une équipe n'importe quoi pas
n'importe quoi tout le monde sait que ça
crée un sentiment de solidarité de
porter le même maillot et c'est la même
chose dans les
écoles
solution la vraie solution c'est que
tout le monde porte le maillot de
l'Olympique de
[Musique]
Marseille rien
contre il peut faire des Vanes ça ça va
là vous ne voulez pas de solution vous
voulez que des problèmes vous êtes des
opposants par principe vous
êtes
fonction
éatunis c'est la même chose ce
raisonnement ce raisonnement de pour ou
contre fonctionnerait cyil s'il n'y
avait pas eu cette parenthèse entre
grosso modo 1968 et il y a 15 ans où
l'école avait de l'autorité et il n'y
avait pas besoin de
d'uniforme or là on essaie de rectifier
le manque d'autorité par le port d'un
costume il y a donc un problème qui
n'est pas lié au costume à l'école même
alors contrairement à mir je bois les
paroles d'éic nollo de Valérie benim et
de Kelly Vedovelli moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous dans les
ver de tout le monde tu attraper
le je ne risque rien parce que Monsieur
divisio est là et du coup voilà il sait
que je suis très vacciné ah donc du coup
non je trouve que ça a beaucoup beaucoup
plus d'avantage que d'inconvénient en
fait déjà très très basiquement déjà je
trouve que dans une époque
d'ensuvagement de violence extrême
d'harcèlement scolaire je pense que
c'est très très bien l'uniforme sorte de
consumérisme où les enfants deviennent
complètement dingu avec des défis TikTok
de est-ce que tu as ça est-ce que tu as
pas ça et tout ça où les enfants se
rendent malades pour savoir comment ils
vont s'habiller la veille avant d'aller
à l'école donc je pense que ça a
beaucoup plus d'avantage évidemment on
connait pas aujourd'hui la mise en place
comment ça va se faire et tout ça mais
dans le privé ça se passe très bien en
fait donc si on tout m dansi il a plus
de violence je
Técoute dit que ser une solution Mirac
j'ai dit pour les professeurs c'est ça
la
solution Alex mais ou aux ÉtatsUnis ou
dans les écoles privées ils ont des
costumes ça a plein d'avantages et
notamment le pouvoir d'achat parce que
les arguments fallacieux de dire oui on
va changer de tissu Mach on est en
France on a les plus grands designers de
mode de la terre on pourra très bien
imaginer qu'on a un qui nous fait des
beau costumes pour tous les écoliers de
France et c'est le même tis les parents
qui pay vous n'importe
quoi pay un vê un
V ch 14 tshirs de marque 25 pantalons de
Mar et chaussures de c'est tout et
aujourd'hui le harcèlement scolire qui
vrai débat un des combat d'ailleurs
lancé par le ministre ça fait partie du
harcèlement scolaire comme tous les
signes de différenciation là aura lieu
ça aura lie la sortie non plus dans la
cour de récréation c'est tout non pas la
sortie j'aimerais j'aimerais que fadé
clôture une minute après je vous dis
dans un instant vous verrez j'ai une
grosse info sur un élève justement qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui par une petite
info c'est rien de grave je vous le dis
voilà mais on a une info sur un élève
que je vous donnerai dans un instant qui
VI qui vient de tomber oui deux choses
d'abord sur les conneries
qu'effectivement je raconte moins que
Gilber des sans doute mais moins qu' on
va bientôt lancer l'échelle de la
connerie Mo aussi parce que en fait SIO
a dit un mot tout à l'heure c'est
fondamental alors si on considère que le
problème de que
l'uniforme est un problème fondamental
c'est qu'on a rien compris que
l'uniforme soit une question qui soit
légitime d'accord mais de dire que
l'uniforme est de problème fondamental
aujourd'hui c'est complètement faux
c'est vous qui l'avez dit je sais bien
qu'effectivement ah si vous l'avez dit
le problème avec c'est
endre la à chaque fois vous nous faites
le même coup à chaque fois ça réglerait
pas le problème à so se excusez-moi je
veux dire fondament pardon vous je sais
qu'effectivement pas grand monde ne vous
écoute mais pour ce qui me concerne
c'est le cas peutendre sil en
soit quoi qu'il en soit effectivement a
employé ce mot de fondamental non c'est
pas un problème fondamental en fait
c'est relativement simple que je dis
tout à l'heure ça dépens qu'on en att
temp mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on
réglera pas le problème de l'école par
l'uniform ça c'est certain certain
certain et que c'est certainement pas
par là qu'il fait commencer il y a des
problèmes il y a des chantiers qu' va
falloir engagé qu' va falloir résoudre
et notamment cette question de
l'appartenance à la communauté éducative
lorsqu'on aura une communauté éducative
alors on se posera la question
anné aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'on
pas de les problèm sont urg et vous
pensez que le problème
urgent je avir la vie des
téléspectateurs sil vous plaî on est en
direct bien entendu oui
79% 80 % des gens
sont à Provin ils ont fait uneexpérience
et donc il y avait 80 % des gens qui
étaient pour il sont partis sur les
chapeaux de roues mais en fait dans la
pratique ça s'est délité très vite au
bout d'un an plus personne vous allez
venir en invité pour parler de ça Liv
80% des gens division et contre c'est
c'est une bonne
idée ça lui arrive d'écouter ou
jamais pas vous nécoutez pas les
autes merci on se retrouve dans un
instant les chéris avec une info sur un
élève aujourd'hui vous allez voir en
image vous allez voir ce sera dans un
instant tout de suite